I guess essentially bought that I don't
know not really dead left married your
mom and had you lost all this money in a
pyramid scheme and put a pistol in his
mouth now you're here it's good to meet
you brother
[Music]
set this is a B you know that NDA's yeah
just and why would he bring me here he
wants to know here once my mother died
our little nuclear family was broken so
on to the next myself did you the news
bring me up here so you could bust my
balls apologize if I came off a bit
strong last night I just want more fun
when you're not sober I don't know what
his deal is but I'm not staying here to
find out you gotta give me a chance to
make it right take the money give him a
second chance just pretend like he's not
the creepiest human just trying to help
Seth you don't have to be here you know
that right you don't have to be in this
house it's complicated one Mississippi
two Mississippi three Mississippi four
Mississippi five Mississippi six
Mississippi seven Mississippi eight
Devine dreaming wake up wake up love 9
now here I come
[Music]
you
[Music]
you